STEPHANIE WONG: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to CE TV, hosted by
Cloud OnAir, where we host
live webinars every Tuesday.
Today, we are going to be
talking about Networking 103.
My name is Stephanie
Wong, Developer Advocate
for Google Cloud.
And today, I'm
joined by Binal Shah,
who is a Networking
Specialist and Customer
Engineer for Google Cloud.
Last time, we spent
a couple sessions
with Ryan Przybyl,
who's also on her team,
covering Networking
101 and 102, where we
talked about VPCs, VPC peering.
We also covered interconnect,
routing, shared VPCs.
So we're going to continue
speaking on that topic
but diving a little bit
deeper into security
and best practices there.
So before we get
started, I also wanted
to mention that you'll have the
opportunity to ask questions
throughout the session.
We will have live
Googlers answering
those on the platform.
And at the end, we'll
save some time for you
all to ask questions, as well.
We'll collect them,
and then we'll
jump back on and
answer them at the end.
So without further
ado, take it away.
BINAL SHAH: Thank
you, Stephanie.
Hi, everyone.
I am Binal Shah, Networking
Specialist at Google.
I work with other customers with
their networking requirements
and architecture
on Google Cloud.
So, today, we're going
to talk about security.
You know, security--
network security
is a big part of
infrastructure design.
You know, whether you are
deploying your environment
on prem or in cloud, right?
There is a requirement
to secure your resources.
Today, we will talk about
some of the best practices
and how you secure the
environment in Google Cloud.
So first thing you would
start with, whenever
you start deploying a
project, first thing you do
is spin up a VPC.
By definition, VPC
is an isolated domain
where no one has access to
it unless you allow access.
So as you're adding users
and assigning them IAM roles,
a good practice is to follow the
principle of least privilege.
So understand a user's
function and then only
allow as much access the
user needs to do their job.
This way you reduce errors
due to this configuration
and thereby reduce downtime.
STEPHANIE WONG: So
this is relating
to IAM policies, Identity and
Access Management permissions
and roles.
BINAL SHAH: That's correct.
And then you start deploying
instances in your VPC.
At that point, you
want to restrict flows
to your instances.
That's how you protect
your instances.
For this, you use
firewall rules.
You know, we'll talk a little
bit more about firewall rules,
but this is a good time--
before you start spinning
up your instances, right--
it's a good time to sit
down with your application
team and network and
security teams together
to identify what flows the
application needs, right?
You do want to make sure
the application runs,
but at the same time, you
want to protect your instances
from unwanted traffic.
All right, now you
have your VPC set up.
The next thing you want to do
is connect back to on prem.
So we have a few ways
we are able to do this.
So let's say you want to
talk to your Google services,
like G Suite.
So in this case, from
on prem to G Suite,
you can deploy
direct peering, where
you peer your router with
one of Google's routers
in the process peering location.
And then Google is your next
hub for all the Google services
traffic.
This way, given that
Google is your next hub,
you're not going
over the internet,
crossing multiple ASNs, so
that reduces your latency
and gives you
better performance.
Now, you also want
to have connectivity
between your servers, and you
want private IP connectivity
between this, right?
Couple options, right?
You can do cloud VPN.
Cloud VPN is our
site-to-site IPsec VPN.
The traffic goes
over the internet,
but it is fully encrypted.
So it is still secure.
Cloud VPN is a good solution
when you have lower bandwidth
requirement, and it's very
quick to set up and get going.
Now, we do have customers--
sometimes they do not
want to let their traffic
go over the internet at all,
or they have very large
volumes of traffic,
so we're talking about
tens of gigs of data.
So for this we have dedicated
interconnect options.
So dedicated interconnect,
again, you connect your on prem
and meet us at one
of the core locations
and connect directly
to Google Cloud.
From there, you put a
VLAN attachment and cloud
router in your VPC.
So you have connectivity
directly into your VPC.
And then between the cloud
router and your on prem router,
you link local BGP
to exchange routes.
STEPHANIE WONG: So, again,
this is internal communication
across.
BINAL SHAH: That is
internal communications.
Your servers will talk using
private IPs, so 10 10, 10 1,
can talk to 190 to
160, for example.
Great.
So we have the
connectivity set up.
Now, oftentimes, we
see customers come in.
They have an
architecture on prem,
and they're using a lot
of vendor solutions,
like next gen
firewall ideas, IBS.
And they would like to
carry that architecture
into Google Cloud, right?
By way of our partner solutions,
they are able to do that.
So they can work
with their partners
and deploy the same solutions in
their Google Cloud environment.
STEPHANIE WONG: OK.
So just to reiterate, you
are able to use third party
appliances and bring
them over to GCP.
BINAL SHAH: Absolutely.
STEPHANIE WONG: That way,
we're able to kind of meet you
where you are.
You can continue to
re-architect in the same way.
BINAL SHAH: Yes.
You know, always look
at what Google offers,
and then, like I said,
customers have their solutions.
They also want to work with
the same vendors that they are,
then we have that capability
in our marketplace
so you can find those vendors.
So now you deployed the
applications in Google Cloud,
and you want to scale.
So you're going to front
it with a load balancer.
So Google's Global
Load Balancers
provide you edge protection
from L3 and L4 attacks.
So Google's Global Load
Balancer also uses anycast IP--
that is one IP
advertised globally.
So you can front end your
application with just one IP.
And you remember the Google's
global infrastructure, right?
Just by the way of the
infrastructure that we have,
customers are able
to have back ends
in different regions
behind their load balances.
So what this does is it
brings the workloads closer
to the user, so
your end user will
see less latency and, hence,
improved performance, right?
STEPHANIE WONG: You mentioned
that this Global Load Balancer
offers L3, L4 protection.
Are there any other
additional ways
that you're able to
protect your applications?
BINAL SHAH: Absolutely.
So we have a product
called Cloud Armor, which
integrates with
the load balancer
and provides
additional protection
from DDOS and for the
applications, right?
In addition, we also have,
again, partner solutions
that customers can use.
Again, customers can
be already using it,
and they want more protection
for the-- specific protection
for the application.
Then these solutions are
still available to use.
STEPHANIE WONG: Awesome.
BINAL SHAH: So now let's
take a little bit deeper dive
into some of these
solutions, right?
So when you spin up
instances in your VPC,
first thing you're going to
do is give it a private IP,
and then you have an
option to add a public IP.
Once you assign a public IP
to an instance, remember,
this instance is accessible
from the rest of the world.
So if your instance
does not need
to be reachable
from the outside,
you don't need to
add a public IP.
This way, you just reduce the
attack surface, for instance.
Now, there are cases where your
instance can have a private IP,
but it still needs
to go out, right?
It needs to get
updates, et cetera.
So it will need
outbound communication.
This we enable using Cloud NAT.
So Cloud NAT is Google's
software defined solution,
so this is not a VM.
This is not an appliance.
It's just a scalable
software solution.
It is regional, so you add
this Cloud NAT in each region.
Then all of the subnets
within that region
can use this NAT to go out.
You also have control over if
you only want a specific subnet
to go out.
You may still not want some
instances to go out at all,
so you do have that
kind of control.
STEPHANIE WONG: So we
also have customers
who might have
been used to using
other architectural setups,
like bastion hosts or proxies.
In addition to having
this Cloud NAT option,
when do you recommend
each kind of use case?
BINAL SHAH: Good
question, Stephanie.
So let's say I
have my instances,
and I need to SSH
into these, right?
I don't want to open SSH
to the entire world, right?
I know who needs to access, so I
can allow just my corporate IPs
to access.
But usually what
do you do, this is
where you use a bastion host.
So you keep one bastion host.
You allow access to that
host, and these instances
can only be accessed
from the bastion host.
That way, that is a lot
more controlled access.
Right?
And you can also use
proxies to go out.
A lot of customers use that.
And one more thing
I wanted to note--
so if you wanted to talk
to Google services--
so your instances wanted
to reach Google services,
like Cloud Storage
or BigQuery, they
can do that using private IP.
So you don't need to
add a public IP just
to access Google services.
STEPHANIE WONG: OK.
That's great.
BINAL SHAH: And
that's pretty neat.
Yes.
Awesome.
Thank you.
So the next step is you
want to restrict flows
to your instance, right?
You want to protect
your instances.
We have Google's
distributed firewalls
that will help with this.
How are they different, right?
It's important to understand.
On the left side, you
see an architecture
that you traditionally
see on prem, right?
So the firewalls are
closer to the edge.
All traffic comes in.
And here's this firewall squared
out through these firewalls.
Sometimes, firewalls
can be a choking point,
but more importantly, once that
traffic leaves the firewall,
there is little
control, no easy way
to control communication
between instances.
So on Google Cloud, our firewall
is a distributed firewall,
and the way it works
is, when a packet
is trying to reach an
instance, the firewall rules
are checked at that
time, and only if there's
a firewall rule that allows
this traffic to the instance
will that packet be allowed.
If there's no firewall
rule, the packet
does not reach that instance.
So as you see in
the diagram, you
can control communication
north-south, as well as
east-west.
So if you look at
this diagram, there
are instances with a
tag, called red tag,
and some instances
with a blue tag.
So when I add my
firewall rule, my rule
will look like source
will be red tag--
ends with red tag--
and destination
will be blue tags.
This is a neat way to group
together similar function VMs.
And what happens is
you've now enabled
east-west communication.
Another option is to use
service accounts on VM.
That's a bit more
secure than tags,
because, with tags, it
needs compute admin--
it still needs compute admin
privilege to change the tag.
That can be done while
the VM is running.
So depending on your use
case, you have options.
STEPHANIE WONG: I see.
And for the use
case of those who
have projects in
different regions
or just have shared
VPC, and they
want internal communication
across multiple projects,
how would you set up firewalls
or communication across them?
BINAL SHAH: Yes.
So a firewall rule is
global within a VPC, right?
So if I have one VPC and
have multiple regions,
there's still going to be
one firewall rule stable.
You add your rules there.
Now, you mentioned the
case of shared VPC.
So in shared VPC, case there's
one VPC in a host project,
and now you are connecting
a lot of service projects
and sharing these subnets with
the different service projects.
So it's a valid point.
You want to control
communication
between these projects, right?
So you still go back
in the host project
and in those shared VPC, and
add firewall rules there.
So shared VPC is
still like a VPC.
You have the ability to
share your subnets down.
So I would say subnet 1
shared with service project 1,
and subnet 2 shared with service
project 2, I would put a rule--
so much communication on
these boards, these protocols,
to these VMs is allowed
between these two projects.
Cool.
By default, all
ingress will be denied.
So only allow-- again, another
principle is only allow access
that you need to.
By default, egress
is all allowed,
but there may be
cases where customers
do want to restrict that, so
you have the ability to do that.
And here is an example
of how firewall rules can
work together in Google Cloud.
Like we said before, before
you deploy applications,
it's a very good idea
to know the flows.
Couple of things,
just from experience,
right, troubleshooting
gets easier.
If you have a blueprint,
anytime an application--
there's issue with
the communication,
you can look at the blueprint
and validate the flows are
allowed, you know?
Firewall rules are not
the cause of downtime.
The other thing is firewall
rules are a finite resource.
So it is important to plan
them before you start adding.
And we talked about tags.
I'm going to just
show an example of how
you can reduce the number of
firewall rules just using tags.
So in this diagram, on the
right is my management subnet.
There are my management VMs.
That will have access to
all the instances, right?
So if you look at the second
rule below that I have written,
my source is going to
be management subnet.
Then my destination
is all instances.
So, actually, from the
drop down in the console,
you can see all
instances in the network.
And then you allow
specific ports.
In this case, I
want to allow a SSH,
and then I also
want to allow ICMP.
So now the next thing is
I have web servers, right?
I will group all the web servers
together based on function
and add a tag www.
And then these web servers
want to talk to app servers
over specific ports.
And I will add a
rule saying, all
VMs with the tag www--
those are my source--
can access VMs with a tag app.
And then the access
should be allowed
for these ports and
these protocols--
in this case, http and https.
STEPHANIE WONG:
So outside of just
the limitation of
firewall rules,
are there other reasons why
tagging in these firewall rules
would be a benefit?
BINAL SHAH: Yeah.
Tagging definitely
helps you group
together similar instances.
So another application
comes on board,
and you have the same rules,
you already allowed it.
You just have to give the right
tag to the instances, right?
So the rule is already there.
You can reuse.
And, remember, firewall
rules have a finite resource,
so you want to make
sure you efficiently
plan your firewall rules.
Firewall rules are also
important between VPC peerings.
So it's critical that you allow
only the flows that you want.
Just a little bit on
VPC peering, right?
VPC peering-- within Google
Cloud, our VPC is global.
So if, within a VPC,
you had instances
running in US West and Europe,
these talk to each other.
So you do not need to peer
these two together, right?
These are still
within the single VPC,
and then they can
talk to each other.
But there are use cases, like
SaaS services, like a large--
bees, right-- a
large organization
having multiple
departments, they
have their different
projects, and, yet,
they need some
communication to be
allowed between cross project.
So that's where you peer VPCs,
and you peer between projects
or across organizations.
Now, when you peer, the routes
are exchanged between these two
VPCs, right?
So in this example,
VPC enterprise 1
has a route to the subnet of
VPC SaaS via the peering link.
Vice versa, VPC SaaS has
access to enterprise subnets
via the VPC peering link.
So now it is the
firewall rules that
will control which instances
talk to which instances.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
So this is still
internal communication
across separate VPCs,
yet you're still
able to maintain that
fine grained control using
these firewall rules.
BINAL SHAH: Yes.
Absolutely.
And, yes, the communication
is not going out.
It is still within
the Google Cloud,
and the instance is able to talk
to each other using private IP.
Keep in mind, though,
the firewall rules tables
are not exchanged
between peers, and this
is for security reasons.
Your tags also will
not be transferred.
So you will use subnets as
source for the peer VPC.
OK.
So we have the
firewall rules set up.
Next thing we need
to know is, when
you start deploying
in Cloud, you
want visibility,
similar to what you have
on prem or other environments.
You want to be able to see what
is going in and out of your VM.
VPC flow logs enables that.
It captures all flows
at the instance level,
so to and from the VM.
It is enabled at
the subnet level,
and then whenever a flow reaches
an instance or a flow goes out,
be this between VM to
VM, or a VM talking to
on prem environment, or a
VM talking to the internet,
you're able to
capture these flows.
Our aggregation is five
seconds, not in minutes.
So it is pretty real time.
Some use cases for
VPC flow logs is,
when you are spinning
up a new environment,
you want to troubleshoot.
So you go into flow logs
further as you need,
and you can check
whether the flows are
working as you expect.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
So following this idea
of your blueprint,
you want to make sure that
everything's according to plan,
according to your
security policies.
When you do look at these
logs, what kind of information
does it actually capture?
BINAL SHAH: It actually captures
a rich set of information.
So if I take any of
the flow log entry,
I would see connection details.
So who is my source IP?
Who is my destination?
Who is it talking to?
What ports and
protocols are used?
And then it'll give me
details of the instance
that the flow is
occurring to or from.
So this is my source VM.
This is the name.
This is the IP, the subnet,
VPC, and the project
that it lives in.
For the source,
that is external.
It will also give me what
ASN it's coming from,
region and continent
details, et cetera.
So it is pretty rich.
I can actually take
all this information
and put it into
BigQuery and generate
a lot of analytics out of it.
I can actually generate
a networking dashboard.
Who are my top talkers?
What is the bandwidth
utilization and egress charge?
So if I see egress by
zones, you know how much--
if anybody looks
at their billing,
it's sometimes confusing.
This will give you
a chart and tell you
how much egress per zone.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
And that was going to be
my other follow up question
is about exporting these logs.
You mentioned BigQuery.
If I wanted to export to my
CM and correlate these logs
with other systems
that I'm using,
would that be a possibility?
BINAL SHAH: Absolutely.
So all of our logs go
to Stackdriver Logging.
That's our tool
for Cloud Logging.
And from here, you have the
capability to export it.
So you can export
to Cloud storage.
A lot of customers have
requirement to store logs
for a certain amount of time.
So you can just export
it to Cloud storage,
and it will be there.
Export it to BigQuery--
we just talked about it.
A lot of rich information.
And using our data
analytics platform,
it also integrates
with Data Studio,
which is our visualization
tool where we can create charts
at any time.
And you mentioned CM--
we can actually stream live
using Pub/Sub to any device
you want.
So good use case for CM
is you want to correlate
all the logs in one place.
So we have that
capability using Pub/Sub.
STEPHANIE WONG: That's great.
BINAL SHAH: OK.
So now you have your
applications front
ended with Global
Load Balancer, and you
want to scale with it, right?
So Global Load Balancer
provides us a lot of advantages.
So, first of all, you know,
when you're using application,
use TLS, right?
Wherever possible, use TLS.
It increases the security,
and Google does not
charge extra for it.
Now Global Load Balancer
is an AnyCast VIP,
so one VIP advertised globally.
So you have one DNS
name mapping to one IP.
And by virtue of our
global infrastructure,
here I have an example.
I have workloads in US
central, US west, US east,
as well as Asia, right?
So my customers in Asia
can access the application
with a lot less latency
than if it were in US west.
Now, Global Load Balancer
supports auto scaling.
What does that mean?
If I have a region
seeing a lot of traffic,
and I plan for the capacity
which is good for every day,
and then, suddenly, there are
times, right, end of the year,
you have a sudden
spike in traffic.
Black Friday, you have
sudden spike in traffic.
You want your application
to be able to handle these.
Then the auto scaling feature
will be able to auto scale
and add instances to absorb that
traffic and support your users.
In addition, Global
Load Balancer also
can do cross region overflow.
So let's say, in US
east, you're suddenly
seeing a lot of traffic, and
it may be unexpected, right?
But by the time you figure
out what's going on,
Global Load Balancer
is intelligent enough
to divert the traffic to
the next closest region.
So, in this case,
US central instances
will start picking
up the traffic,
and your customers will not see
downtime, and that's important.
STEPHANIE WONG: That's amazing.
And this is all
supported, of course,
by our large number of points
of presence and data centers
globally.
I see that our CDN is also
on this slide, as well.
How does this fit into
this overall picture?
BINAL SHAH: Absolutely.
So CDN enables you to
cache content at the edge.
So you may have
frequent requests
for certain information.
You enable CDN.
CDN integrates with
load balance-- http,
https Load Balancer, right?
So you enable CDN for
your back end service,
and it'll start caching
content at the edge.
So now when requests come in,
it'll be solved at the edge.
Now you just offloaded
your back end service
from a lot of requests.
OK.
Another solution that
we have is Cloud Armor.
That provides DDOS protection at
the edge to your applications.
Cloud Armor also integrates
with Global Load Balancer.
Now, we know, right,
that instances are
protected by firewall rules.
Cloud Armor works at the
edge to restrict access
to the global VIP, because
the global VIP we'll
have a public IP.
This way, here in
this example, I
have instances at the back end.
They are protected
by firewall rules.
Remember, Global Load Balancers
are proxy load balances.
So the source IP is
going to be different.
It's going to be
the load balancer
IPs, as seen from the
instance perspective, right?
So, that traffic,
you want to make
sure you only allow the
ports and protocols that you
want to allow--
the traffic you want to allow.
Now, at the edge, the traffic
is coming from a client, right?
So that's where
Cloud Armor comes in,
and you're going to be
having control over which IPs
you're going to allow, right?
So in this case,
as an example, I'm
going to allow my corporate IPs
to access this load balancer.
Or I may have specific customers
I have this application for,
and I'll allow only their IPs.
And then I can say,
deny everything else.
STEPHANIE WONG: So this
is sort of speaking
to that multilayer
defense where, of course,
we provided DDOS protection
at the load balancer level,
but, from the edge,
we want to protect
from even allowing traffic
from those source edge IPs.
BINAL SHAH: Absolutely.
STEPHANIE WONG: Now,
a lot of our customers
I know also wonder about being
able to not only white list
IPs, but also have the
ability to blacklist IPs.
Is that something that
Cloud Armor would enable?
BINAL SHAH: It can.
Absolutely.
So I have my service open to
everyone, all who needs to.
But I'm seeing-- like,
I'm seeing the logs,
and I'm suddenly seeing traffic
from somebody you don't want.
And you're going to
find those IPs and say,
I don't want this particular.
I don't know.
It's not my customer.
It's not my corporate.
I need to block this IP.
So you can add rules to
your Cloud Armor policy
specifically for that
IP or a set of IPs
and restrict that communication.
STEPHANIE WONG: OK.
That's great.
BINAL SHAH: So that's a great
way to block unwanted traffic.
All right.
So here is an example
that shows I have my https
Global Load Balancer
configured with the back ends,
and I'm going to configure
Cloud Armor policy.
Here, my corporate IP
range is 50.1.0.0/16,
so I'm going to add a rule to
my policy, allow 50.1.0.0/16.
Now, as you see, employees in
San Francisco and Singapore
are going to be able to
access the service fine,
but you see someone with
an IP 120.1.1 is coming in.
And that is not your employee.
So that traffic
would be blocked.
STEPHANIE WONG: Now,
one other question
that I start to
think about is just
the difference between setting
up Cloud Armor versus also
setting up firewall rules
for your specific compute
instances.
BINAL SHAH: Yeah.
So firewall rules protect
the compute instance.
So we will look at
this example, right?
So my user comes in
with an IP 50.1.1.5
and has access to the
Load Balancer VIP, right?
The load balancer is
a proxy load balancer,
so it's going to
terminate that connection
and open a new connection
to the back end.
So from my instance
perspective I
have the source as
the load balancer IP,
and the destination
is my instance.
So the firewall rule will
have a source of destination--
source of the load balancer
IP and port-- let's say 4.4.3.
Please allow this traffic.
Anything else?
Block that traffic.
But in this case, if
I were not having--
so this allowed, but
there is no way--
my source will always be the
load balancer IP in this case.
STEPHANIE WONG: That's
going to remain the same.
BINAL SHAH: Yeah.
So how do I protect
my front end?
So Cloud Armor will come in
and say, OK, I'll protect you
from the client IPs, right?
So that's where I'm saying,
50.1.1.0/16 is what I'm going
to allow.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
And that can vary so
much more in terms
of the number of clients
that could be trying
to access that load balancer.
BINAL SHAH: Yes.
This can be globally.
STEPHANIE WONG: Great.
Awesome.
BINAL SHAH: All right.
So I think let's try to look
at some of the configurations
of what we talked about, right?
We talked about a lot of things.
How does it look in
Google Cloud console now?
So I have some
instances created here.
I have a management
instance, and I have
assigned an external IP to it.
Now, if you look at
the other instances,
they do not have external IP.
I can try to go into
any one instance,
and we will see
the configuration.
Right?
So my instance is in the US
west1 b zone, has a primary IP,
does not have an external IP.
I have also added a
tag to it saying www,
if you remember our
previous example.
OK.
So now I want to SSH
into this instance.
So let me SSH here.
So I'm going to go into
my management instance,
and, from there, I can
access all the instances.
I also have some
instance groups here.
So we're going to walk through
a Global Load Balancer set up.
My instance groups will
also have the same tags.
So my template should have
the tags that I want to have.
OK.
So here I am.
Now, I want to
SSH into 10.2.1.2.
So this is my internal
instance, right?
So, remember, I want
to be able to go out
to get updates, et cetera.
So I want to external
reachability.
So how do I do that, right?
So I need to add Cloud NAT,
as we had discussed earlier.
So to be able to
find Cloud NAT, you
go into Products, Networking,
Network Services, Cloud NAT.
And I have a NAT gateway
configured already.
We just go through
the configuration.
This is in my VPC, and
the region US west1,
that's where my instances are.
And, here, I'm saying all
subnets primary and secondary
will be able to
access my Cloud NAT.
I do have an option to say
specific subnets, right?
So, here, I can
say Custom, Range,
and then I would
say only my demo--
my web servers would be
able to go out, right?
Things like that.
So I have the option
of doing that.
I can also say,
only primary ranges.
Subnets can't have
secondary ranges.
But you may not want
those to go out.
So you have control like that.
I already have a
gateway connected,
so let's go to my instance.
And let's see if we
are able to go out.
Yep.
Without a public IP,
I am able to go out.
So that's pretty neat.
Now let's look at our
load balancer setup.
So this was my NAT setup.
We already saw this.
We talked about VPC flow logs.
So I just want to walk through
one of the entry, how it looks,
and what information
you're able to see.
So we did SSH.
I am able to-- this is our
Stackdriver login screen.
I am able to filter.
So, here, I want to see who
all SSHed into my instance.
So I will say destination port
22 and the IP of the instance
that I want to look into,
and here is a typical entry.
So I have connection details,
the destination, the source--
in this case, this
is my management VM--
and the destination port is 22.
So I know there
was an SSH action,
and these are the details
on the destination instance.
It tells me the instance
name and the region
and the project that
the instance lives in.
And of course,
there's a timestamp.
And then there's
a source instance,
details if the
source is within VPC,
used by a similar instance.
Details-- if it
is external, it'll
give you more details on
the origin of the user.
Perfect.
It also tells me
reporter's destination.
That means the flow is
to my VM in this case.
All right.
Now let's quickly take a look at
the Global Load Balancer setup.
So I have a load balancer setup.
I have a global web, and
I have https enabled.
And I will have
a back end to it.
Now, I also have a Cloud
Armor policy configured here.
So I go to Network
Security and Cloud Armor,
and then I have a policy
that will allow to everyone,
but I know I don't want
to allow specific ranges,
so I will have one
deny policy, and then
I am OK to allow
to my corporate.
In this case, I'm allowed
to the rest of the world.
I can go in-- this is-- my
last rule is my default rule--
I can go in and set it to deny.
If I do deny, I do have
options to configure what kind
of response the user will see.
So it can be 403, 404, or 502.
So you have the flexibility
of configuring that.
STEPHANIE WONG:
So I see here this
is how you white list versus
blacklist in IP ranges.
BINAL SHAH: Absolutely.
Now, let's look at
some of the logs here.
So I am going to try to send
this one request to the user,
and I am able to see because
I have actually opened it up
to the world.
And if I look at any one
particular log entry,
you will go into
http load balancer.
And then you see
enforce security policy.
So it will tell you this rule--
hit which policy rule, right?
This flow, hit
which policy rule.
So, in this case,
the security policy
was configured to accept.
The name of the policy was
cloud-armor-policy-glb-https.
And the outcome was accept.
Now, I could have
had a deny here,
and it will show me which
policy was triggered.
And here is the detail
of the forwarding rule
that was tried to access and
then the zone configuration.
All right?
That's all I had.
STEPHANIE WONG: Great.
Thank you.
I think it was really nice
to see it visually in terms
of the flow logs
between either hitting
the load balancer versus
your specific instances
in the back end.
BINAL SHAH: Yes.
It is actually-- I would
highly encourage you, just go
to Google Cloud, and
look at these options.
Cloud Armor sits under Network
Security, Cloud NAT Load
Balancing under
Networking Services.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
I see it's giving
a lot of options
for reducing that attack
surface by preventing you
from always having any of your
instances open to the public.
So there's a lot of options
here to protect our VMs.
BINAL SHAH: And keep checking.
We have a lot more features
coming out, so yeah.
STEPHANIE WONG: Well,
thank you so much.
We do have a couple of minutes
to just collect some questions,
and we'll just be
back in a minute,
and we'll try to
answer some of them.
BINAL SHAH: Sure.
STEPHANIE WONG: All right.
Welcome back.
We have a few
questions that we'd
love to get answered for you
all that we've just collected.
The first one, which is,
can I enforce firewall rules
for other services
like App Engine?
BINAL SHAH: So you can.
App Engine firewalls use the
same firewall rules table,
so firewall rules work
for GC, GKE, App Engine.
STEPHANIE WONG: OK.
Great.
And the next question
is, can I control
communication between two
subnets using a third party
firewall?
BINAL SHAH: So this
is a good question.
So when you said two
subnets, within a VPC,
when you create subnets,
these are local subnets,
and there will always be a
local route generated for that.
So if I want to go to subnet
1, VPC 1, to subnet 2, VPC 2,
VPC 1 is going to be the
local generated route.
So this communication cannot
go to an external next hop
and come back.
However, between two VPCs--
so a good use case for
a third party firewall
is you have multiple
VPCs, and you
want to see communication
between these two VPCs.
That's when you use a
third party firewall.
You spin up an instance
with multi NIC,
and you can have
one NIC in each VPC.
And, that way, your
next hop-- so when you
want to communicate
with subnet 1 and VPC 1
with subnet 1 and VPC 2,
can configure the next hop
as the third party firewall,
and your communication
would go through the
firewall so the firewall gets
the visibility it needs to get.
STEPHANIE WONG: OK.
So there's two things there.
You can set up multiple
NICs on a single VM,
and then also that,
if you are using
two subnets in the same
VPC, those are actually
using local routes,
which is why you
wouldn't be able to use a third
party firewall, in that case.
BINAL SHAH: Yeah.
So even if you
add a route, route
can have priorities, like
even if you added out
with a lower priority for two
subnets within the same VPC,
that route is going
to be disabled.
The local route will
always be preferred.
I
Do want to go back to your
point for third party firewalls.
Yes, you need to
use a multi NIC VM.
So a typical use case
for third party firewall
is you have an
outside interface,
and then you have at least
one inside interface.
So you can have a multi NIC VM
with up to eight interfaces,
and then you have the
inside configured and then
the outside VPC so that
instance has a leg in each,
and then the firewall
controls the communication.
STEPHANIE WONG: I see.
OK.
Our next question is, can I log
firewall rule activity, which
I think we might have covered
in the presentation, but yes.
BINAL SHAH: Actually, yes.
You can log firewall
rules activity.
So for each rule,
there's an option.
You can enable logging, right?
So all connections--
now, this is not sampled.
All connections would be logged.
So it's a good use case
for troubleshooting.
Also, when you suspect
something is going on,
you can start logging.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
So you want to
measure and keep a log
of whether or not
things were accessed
and whether those firewall
rules were being used.
BINAL SHAH: And, again, these
logs go into our Stackdriver
Logging, so you are able to see
it there, as well as export it
to where we want.
STEPHANIE WONG: OK.
Our next question
here is, when I
block traffic using Cloud Armor,
what response code or message
does the user receive?
BINAL SHAH: So when you
configure a rule to deny,
you have the option
to configure, what is
the message the user will see?
You can configure
a 404 error, 502,
or you can say
forbidden, so 403.
STEPHANIE WONG: OK.
I think we saw
that in your demo,
as well, that you
get that dropdown.
And our last one is,
can you elaborate
on how you control
traffic between projects
that are using a shared VPC?
BINAL SHAH: Yeah.
So shared VPC is a way to scale
with larger organizations,
right?
Typically, on prem, you have
network and security functions,
so you have network
admin, security admins,
and then there are
application web admins, right?
Web admins don't
necessarily spin up subnets
and add firewall rules,
where a network admin needs
to have control
over the IPs that
are being used across projects,
the security rules that
are being added.
So shared VPC enables that.
So your networking
and security function
is centralized in
the host project.
That's where the VPC lives.
Now, that VPC you shared with
different projects, service
projects, so these are the
projects, like web projects,
you connect to the
host VPC, and they're
called service projects.
So as you share subnets
with these service projects,
the compute admin
over there will
be able to spin up instances,
but not add firewall rules.
So the firewall
rules function still
stays in the host
project, and you still
use firewall rules to do that.
STEPHANIE WONG: OK.
So, again, you do
use firewall rules,
even if you are
using shared VPC.
BINAL SHAH: Yes.
It is a single VPC still, right?
It is one VPC.
And you still use the
firewall rules just the way
you use in other VPCs.
STEPHANIE WONG: Great.
All right.
So I think that's all
the questions we have.
Thank you so much, Binal, again
for giving us this deep dive
on security best practices.
I've truly enjoyed
going more in-depth
about security and networking.
BINAL SHAH: Thank you very much.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah,
thank you so much.
So please, again, stay tuned.
We do have more sessions coming
up today for Cloud On Air.
Our next one is power innovation
for SAP with Google Cloud.
So stick around.
Thanks again.
BINAL SHAH: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]